[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
une femme qui ont dans un sex-shop l on
prend un bleu avait un rouge et la
caissière les passants caisse elle dit
le bleu et le vert ça va me le rouge
sauf demande au patron ces extincteurs
moelleux elle passe bien elle et
familiale
ses textes sont bien écrits je trouve
qu'elle est ton secret merci beaucoup
c'est marrant parce qu'il m'a fallu du
temps avant d'accepter ce compliment
genre je mettais pas mes textes j'ai
imprimé pas mes textes dans les livrets
de mes albums parce que parce que je
trouvais que ça voulait dire qu'en gros
j'étais ultra fier de mes textes et donc
je le faisais pas et après je me suis
rendu compte que ça a aidé simplement
les gens à pouvoir comprendre les textes
donc pour le prochain je les fais
et je suis plus à l'aise avec le fait
que j'écris pas si mal mais en fait
c'est peut-être parce que c'est pas très
chouette décrire fin pour montrer ce pas
un grand place est pas vraiment un
plaisir mais c'est peut-être peut-être
parce que je me casse trop la tête ou je
sais pas mais en même temps je crois que
j'ai comparé ma façon d'écrire avec
cette d'orelsan parce que souvent quand
j'y pense quand je bloque sur mes textes
je l'appelle en fait et c'est ce que
j'ai fait pour multitude et en fait il
est il est venu et il m'a montré la
façon dont il écrivait et franchement
c'est vraiment impressionnant fin lui il
va vraiment loin quoi boccaccio d'or
[Musique]
paris
allo salut ça va je m'appellerai le sann
watros bien et ma soeur a les crocs trop
fameux compas à ces marins et tu vois à
lui renvoyer délicat fort vidéo se plaît
ça lui donnerait trop de la force allé à
l'hôpital pour un cancer
à ces marins
[Applaudissements]
salut les amis je suis avec philippe on
vient de faire une petite séance de
sport avec avec six ou dix règles et
absence de musculation afin de coucher
ensemble des tractions on va transpirer
c'est parti c'est parti